hello
welcome to the european parliament my
name is pavel ciçek work here and i
would like to show you how it
is here at home inside the
european parliament but first look
here we are in the agora the space
in front of the parliament
the agora is named after simone veil the
first president european parliament
the building is named after to tell the
faithful and an italian founding father of
the european union is here you see
quotes our information center
so come follow me and  seeing what
is happening inside
here we are in the hemicycle one of the
seats of the european parliament
all 751 european deputies meet
here with the members of the council and the
commission and the guests we are going to
meet one of the ushers to discuss
know a little more about their role in
the hemicycle where you may have
seen them
he wears a black kick and a
gold or silver chain
welcome to the hemicycle of the
european parliament  en
my name is alan i am danish and with
my 140 colleagues we assist the
european deputies
we also ensure their safety
for example
we have to check each person who
enters the hemicycle we also have to
maintain order while remaining
discreet and flexible  one of the main
difficulties of our work is to
memorize all the names and faces
of the MEPs, especially after the
elections when their mandate begins
and there are hundreds of new
MEPs
we are now von entrances to
the hemicycle a few  only moments
before the start of the plenary session
deputies arrive for the debate and the
vote over the years great
historical moments have taken place here at
the sending behind the scenes of the
engine room or and centralizing the management
of the facilities of the conferences  the
technology to record and
count voices is awesome
hello my name is la horie i
work for  the
european parliament's conference technicians unit i make
sure that all
sound and conference facilities are running smoothly
we work closely
with interpreters and
transmission services to ensure the best
sound for meps there are 24
languages here at  european parliament
we also maintain and will improve
the conference facilities
between meetings for example we recently
upgraded the equipment replacing
more than 450 microphones here on the
control panel we activate the various
microphones
throughout the year we are
also working  for shows special events
when MPs organize a concert
with a band from their constituency
you never get bored here
[Music]
you must be wondering
what to call it would go broadcast live and
translated simultaneously into twenty
four languages  official it's actually
the work of some of the
most  talents of the european parliament
the interpreters the interpreter is responsible for
translating orally from one language
to another
their work is different from that of
translators who translate texts
let's meet one of the
interpreters
her name is simone
hello I  my name is simone i'm an
interpreter for the european parliament
i work in the english booth the
job of an interpreter is to help
meps and their guests to
communicate with each other in their own
language
it's wonderful to be able to help
people  coming from all over europe and
around the world to understand each other
the interpreter is also responsible for
making parliament more accessible if you
go to the parliament's website
you can watch the debates and
hear our voices when we
interpret as it is  the case
today in plenary
we interpret very
diverse personalities from the presidents of the prime
ministers to the men and women
politicians  representatives of
civil society and even citizens
my colleagues and I facilitate
public debates at European level and
allow people to express and
share their ideas in languages
uropeans are able to under
tand as yo
see  interpreters are
there to help you
[Music]
the lights go out it's time
to say goodbye but I hope to
see you again very soon for new
discoveries on the European parliament
[Music]